stargate universe's biggest crime was
that
it was boring
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so here we go i am responding to matt's
video from tuesday there'll be a link in
the description where he argued that sgu
was a masterpiece that it was
very underrated and he doesn't
understand why anybody would dislike it
right so first of all i'm going to say i
don't hate stargate universe um
i love stargate as a whole and i
actually would rather watch target
universe than watch 90 of everything
else that's on television i actually
love stargate universe but it is the
weakest out of the franchise and i can't
help but be a little bit angry at it
because it is the show that ended the
franchise welcome to the destiny general
hello sir
corporal sorry about that sir
there are reasons why i am angry at
stargate universe and some of these
reasons are why if brad wright didn't
showrun the next series of stargate when
it finally makes her screens if that i
might not be that angry about it because
even though he showrun my favorite tv
show ever stargate hg1
he also did sgu but by the way guys if
you are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification it
really helps us out also if you enjoy
the content please consider becoming a
fully fledged sidetracker and hitting
the join button also you can go and pick
merchandise from psydustrec.com link in
the description and you can pick which
team alongside that you want to join sg1
sgu or sga as well as other really great
t-shirts and mugs and everything here
are my reasons why
for one and this is again my the biggest
crime stargate universe made is that it
was boring
the joy was missing the humor was
missing in stargate atlantis we had the
relationship between shepherd and mckay
and ronan at times
you shot me
yes rodney i shot you and i said i was
sorry
you shot me too i'm sorry for shooting
everyone
there was that constant bounce not
featured in that humor
sgu completely lacked that there were a
few good characters in stargate universe
i really did like eli wallace and i hope
they go and save him i really liked uh
rush's character um he was the guy you
love to hate
but there was a lot of characters in
stargate universe that were
distinctly forgettable i actually forgot
that an actress i absolutely adore
mingwa wan was even in this series until
i watched it again about a year and a
half ago colonel young's character
was at time very dramatic
very well acted very well written
but a little boring his relationship
with rush was one of anger and near
hatred at times there was no joy in it
um if you think about shepherd's
character with mckay how you know a time
shepherd wanted to punch mckay in the
face
but the banter between them was at times
very funny
there was none of that in stargate
universe eli was at times the
comedy value but
it wasn't really ever laugh out loud
funny but
when we were walking over that last tune
i thought i saw the statue of liberty
stick in half out of the sand just for a
second there he was trying to find his
way in a place where he was being
bullied quite a lot by rush now you
could say that was because the situation
they were it was very serious and there
was no time for humor but i could tell
you in lots of the jobs i've had over
the years i've worked in very stressful
situations and for me as soon as the
situation becomes very stressful
people's dark sense of humor does tend
to come out people do tend to crack
jokes that
in other situations would be
very inappropriate um but humor does
come through humor is a coping strategy
people do make jokes to try to cope with
what's going on they seem to forget
about that in sgu i also felt watching
stargate universe that brad wright and
joseph pelosi and everyone else that was
involved had seen allstar galactica and
were obviously very impressed by it they
seemed to have been inspired by that
when they then went in to make sgu
the style of sgu is very different to
what we've seen before it was a lot
darker they used music and sound very
differently the
pace of the show was very different
it did seem that
they were inspired by what they've seen
battlestar galactica doing and maybe if
i'm being cynical they wanted to do
something with a bit more art than what
they've done previously
the side effect of that was that it's
less entertaining
it's not as much fun
um and even though they create a show
that was stylistically beautiful and
beautifully made and beautifully
produced
it wasn't particularly entertaining
another big problem with sgu was they
never really focused in on what the
villain was now i've argued in videos
before that any good show to become
great needs a good villain
returned fire it was one of the things
sg-1 did best that they kept creating
new villains though there was always
some new
bad guy to them to go and worry about
sgu
they had villains
but they were forgettable
i would have to google it now to tell
you what they were called but there was
one big problem with sgu and one thing
that nobody can really argue against
it never got the time it deserved to
develop for one towards the end of
series two it was becoming more
entertaining it was building up a bit of
pace it was getting a bit of momentum
definitely halfway through season two it
became far more watchable and boring is
not a word that could be used to
describe it i would also argue that lots
of tv shows take a while to get going
that the first season
you have to tell so much story you have
to get to know all these new characters
there is a lot of development that needs
to happen in a new series
we generally as an audience want to skip
that bit we seem to want to get straight
into it it's a big problem with
streaming services nowadays that with 10
episodes you don't really get to know a
character so you don't get to care about
them
in sgu there was a lot of story to tell
there was a lot of character development
to go on and that was at times a bit
boring and a bit dull
but it was getting better
lots of sci-fi shows over the years have
suffered from this stargate
sg1 was the first series was a little
boring at times there was a lot going on
a lot of stories to tell a lot of
development happened it was a little
boring star trek the next generation
first series until they basically
shipped geordi down to engineering
killed off tasha yar and rejigged the
crew
it was a little bit dull there was two
or three episodes in the first series
that really stood out but other than
that it was a bit forgettable it was
about halfway through season two that it
really kicked off
staying with star trek deep space nines
first two seasons are not great and
voyage's first two seasons are not great
but they kept going they're allowed to
develop and they became the great show
that i personally now adore so yeah i am
not a big fan of sgu i would still
rather watch it than watch 90 of
everything else that's on the telly but
out of the three series it's by far the
weakest
but what do you think do you agree with
me or do you agree with matt go watch
his video and
let him explain to you why he loves the
show get in the comments and tell us
exactly what you think
if you are new to the channel please
like and subscribe and hit that bell
notification it really helps us out also
if you would like to become a fully
fledged side tracker you can support the
channel by hitting the join button as
always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you